D
EMILY COMPAGNO.
ALSO JOINING US, LARA TRUMP AND
BRIAN BRENBERG.
TO ANOTHER BIG STORY, THE FBI'S
CONTROVERSIAL ARREST OF A
PRO-LIFE CATHOLIC FATHER AT HIS
HOUSE IN FRONT OF HIS FAMILY,
THAT IS NOW RAISING QUESTIONS
OVER WHETHER THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE USED AN UNNECESSARY SHOW
OF POTENTIALLY DEADLY FORCE AND
WHY THEY DID IT.
MARK HOUCK IS SET TO BE
ARRAIGNED JUST ABOUT AN HOUR
FROM NOW.
HE IS A HUSBAND, A FATHER OF
SEVEN CHILDREN, AND ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF A CATHOLIC MEN'S
MINISTRY.
THE CHARGES STEM FROM AN
INCIDENT THIS TIME LAST YEAR AS
72-YEAR-OLD PATIENT ESCORT
VOLUNTEERING OUTSIDE OF THE
PHILADELPHIA PLANNED PARENTHOOD
ACCUSED HOUCK OF SHOVING HIM TO
THE GROUND.
HOUCK SAID HE WAS DEFENDING HIS
12-YEAR-OLD SON FROM HARASSMENT,
AND THE DOJ INDICTED HOUCK UNDER
THE FACE ACT, WHICH MAKES IT A
FEDERAL CRIME TO FORCIBLY
INTERFERE WITH SOMEONE FEASTING
THE MIKE SEEKING OR PROVIDING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
ON FRIDAY, THE FBI DESCENDED ON
HIS HOME TO ARREST HIM.
THE FBI ADMITS THAT THE 20
AGENTS CAME TO HIS DOOR WITH
GUNS DRAWN.
HOUCK'S WIFE, RYAN-MARIE, CALLED
THE USE OF FORCE TRAUMATIC AND
SAID THE CHILDREN WERE
TERRIFIED, TELLING FOX NEWS THEY
SAID THEY WERE GOING TO BREAK IN
IF HE DIDN'T OPEN IT, AND THEY
HAD ABOUT FIVE GUNS POINTED AT
HER HUSBAND, AND HER KIDS.
THE FBI IS CALLING THE CLAIMS
INACCURATE.
EMILY, THIS IS EXTRAORDINARY.
I SAW THE SATURDAY MORNING AND I
SAID THERE HAS TO BE MORE TO THE
STORY.
AS IT TURNS OUT, THE "MORE TO
THE STORY" IS THE FACT THAT THE
LOCAL D.A. DECIDED NOT TO BRING
THE CHARGES, AND THEY SAY,
"WELL, IT'S INACCURATE, OUR GUNS
WERE NOT POINTED AT THEM."
THE POINT IS YOU'RE GOING AFTER
A PRO-LIFE ACTIVIST, NOT THE GUY
WHO IS RAIDING A McDONALD'S
WITH AN AX, NOT THE GUY MOWING
DOWN AN 18-YEAR-OLD WHO HE
HIMSELF CALLED A REPUBLICAN
EXTREMIST.
I GET THAT THERE IS FEDERAL AND
STATE LAWS AT PLAY HERE, BUT THE
POINT IS YOU'RE GOING AFTER A
PRO-LIFE ADVOCATE FOR SHOVING
SOMEONE, WHICH APPARENTLY CAUSED
A BAND-AID AND NOTHING MORE THAN
THAT.
>> Emily: HOW ARE AMERICANS TO
EXCEPT THE, THAT THIS IS HOW THE
FBI IS UTILIZED AND HOW THE
F.A.C.E. ACT IS UTILIZED?
UNFORTUNATELY I'VE SEEN THIS A
LOT IN MY CAREER, THE ABSOLUTE
OVER A SHOW OF FORCE IN
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS.
IT'S TOTALLY UNNECESSARY AND THE
FBI SAYS IT'S ACCORDING TO
STANDARDS AND PRACTICES.
THAT IT'S PURSUANT TO AN ARREST
WARRANT.
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THAT
WAY.
I'VE SEEN IT SO MANY TIMES, 6:00
IN THE MORNING FOR NONVIOLENT
CHARGE, A WHITE COLORED CHARGE,
FOR EXAMPLE.
GUNS DRAWN, 50 AGENTS, IN MY
OPINION IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE
BECAUSE IT KEEPS HAPPENING.
AND YET THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
TO FEEL UNSAFE AS AX WIELDING
MEN RIDE THE SUBWAY WITH THEM
AND BE 80-YEAR-OLD WOMEN.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY UNCONSCIONABLE.
LET'S GO BACK TO THIS FOR
SECOND.
HERE'S WHAT ELSE IS
UNCONSCIONABLE.
SINCE THE RELEASE OF THE SCOTUS
OPINION ON MAY 3RD, WE HAVE OVER
104 INSTANCES OF EXTREMIST
VIOLENCE AGAINST PREGNANCY
RESOURCE CENTERS, AND PRO-LIFE
ACTIVISTS.
JUST LAST WEEK, AND 83-YEAR-OLD
WOMAN WAS REPORTED SHOT BECAUSE
SHE WAS ENGAGING IN PRO-LIFE
ACTIVISM.
AND YET, HOW MANY INSTANCES HAVE
WE SEEN OF THE F.A.C.E. ACT
BEING USED TO PROSECUTE AGAINST
THEM?
OR ANY CHARGE?
ZERO.
>> Lara: NOT A SINGLE ARREST
THAT I KNOW OF.
>> Emily: THAT'S RIGHT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL REFUSES TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT.
SENATOR HAWLEY CALLS IT AN
EPIDEMIC OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
PRO-LIFE ADVOCATES, AND HE IS
CALLING ON THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO TESTIFY IN FRONT OF CONGRESS.
HE SAYS ANSWER FOR IT, ANSWER
FOR THOSE LACK OF CHARGES, FOR
THE SELECTIVE USE OF THE
F.A.C.E. ACT, AND THE CLEAR
POLITICAL WEAPONIZATION OF IT
AGAINST A TOTALLY HARMLESS,
NONVIOLENT MAN WHO WAS ARRESTED
IN FRONT OF HIS SEVEN CHILDREN
WITH GUNS DRAWN, ACCORDING TO
THEIR REPORTS COME AT 7:00 IN
THE MORNING.
>> Kayleigh: WE HAVE A PICTURE
OF HIM HERE WITH HIS SEVEN
CHILDREN AND HIS WIFE.
I WAS IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
WEEKEND AND I HAD A WOMAN COME
UP TO ME AND SAY, "I RUN A
PREGNANCY CRISIS CENTER.
MY PREGNANCY CRISIS CENTER WAS
ATTACKED."
AS EMILY MENTIONED, SHE IS ONE
OF 104.
THESE TEND TO BE THE VICTIMS,
AND YET, TO LARA'S POINT, NOT A
SINGLE PROSECUTED CASE IN THESE
INSTANCES.
>> Harris: I WANT TO GO BACK
TO SOMETHING THAT SEEMS A LITTLE
BIT MORE FAMILIAR THAN IT SHOULD
BE, AND THAT IS HOW THE FBI IS
DOING ITS JOB RIGHT NOW.
NORMALLY WHEN THESE THINGS
HAPPEN THEY DON'T SPEAK ON IT,
SO NOW I HAVE MORE QUESTIONS TO
PUT THEM ON THE DEFENSIVE.
WHEN THEY SAY, "IT DIDN'T HAPPEN
EXACTLY THIS WAY, IT HAPPEN THIS
WAY.
THE GUNS WEREN'T POINTED AT THE
KIDS."
THE HOUCK FAMILY SPOKE ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENED.
WE HAVE SEEN OTHER AMERICANS
WHERE RAIDS HAVE HAPPENED WHO
SPOKE ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS A NEED
FOR THAT EXCESSIVE SHOW OF
FORCE, THEY ARE ON THE DEFENSIVE
ONCE AGAIN.
WHY DOES THE FBI KEEP FINDING
ITSELF IN A POSITION TO HAVE TO
DEFEND ITSELF?
WHAT IS GOING ON SUCH THAT THOSE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING IN SUCH A
WAY, THOSE RAIDS ARE ROLLING OUT
IN SUCH A WAY THAT THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN'T DO THE BLANKET
BOILERPLATE "WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
THAT?"
MY GUESS IS THERE ARE CAMERAS
AROUND, WHICH WE SAW WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HOME DOWN IN
FLORIDA.
THERE ARE CHILDREN.
THE INNOCENTS, THEY WILL REPEAT
THE STORIES THAT LEFT THEM SO
FRIGHTENED.
THE FBI IS DOING SOMETHING
DIFFERENTLY, AND IF IT'S NOT,
THEN SHOW US HOW IT'S SUPPOSED
TO BE DONE.
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW HAS
A LOT OF US QUESTIONING WHETHER
OR NOT THEY KNOW HOW TO DO THEIR
JOBS IN A SAFE WAY, PARTICULARLY
WHEN THERE ARE PEOPLE THERE WHO
AREN'T NECESSARILY KNOWN TO BE
OVERLY VIOLENT.
ILLEGAL CHARGE IS A LEGAL
CHARGE.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
MIDDLE OF WHO SHOVED WHO.
THEY WILL EITHER ADJUDICATE THAT
OR THEY WON'T WHEN THE CHARGES
ARE DROPPED.
MAYBE THE FBI WILL COME BACK FOR
ANOTHER BITE BECAUSE THE DOJ
DOES.
WE DON'T KNOW YET.
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THIS
LOOKS SHADY ON THE PART OF THE
FBI, BECAUSE THEY KEEP DEFENDING
THEMSELVES.
SO WHY IS THAT?
>> Kayleigh: IT'S A GREAT
POINT THAT THEY ARE SPEAKING OUT
ON CASES THEY NORMALLY STAY
SILENT ABOUT.
THE F.A.C.E. ACT HAS BEEN USED
ABOUT A DOZEN TIMES.
IN FACT, IN ANOTHER
JURISDICTION, AND PENNSYLVANIA,
IT WAS DISMISSED AND THEY SAID
YOU CAN'T USE IT AGAINST SIMPLE
ASSAULT CASE.
WE HEAR IT'S BEING USED, LARA.
I GET, AGAIN, THAT THERE ARE
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS IN THE
JURISDICTION OVER THESE FEDERAL
ONES.
UNLESS THERE IS A CIVIL RIGHTS
APPLICATION.
BUT YOU CAN'T DISMISS THE
JUXTAPOSITION OF IMAGES WE SEE
IN NEW YORK CITY, PEOPLE BEING
PUSHED INTO SUBWAYS, LITTLE
BABIES BEING SHOT, AGAINST A
PRO-LIFE ACTIVIST WHO TAKES HIS
ROSARY TO A CLINIC WITH HIS
CHILDREN AND PRAISE AND TRIES TO
HELP WOMEN IN A TIME OF NEED.
THERE IS SOMETHING AWRY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Lara: I THINK IT'S VERY
FRUSTRATING FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO SEE.
THIS IS WHERE THE RESOURCES ARE
BEING USED, THAT THERE IS NO ONE
ADDRESSING WHAT YOU'RE SAYING,
KAYLEIGH.
ALL THESE INCIDENTS WE CONTINUE
TO SEE.
CRIME IS ON THE RISE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN A
SINGLE ARREST, TO GO BACK TO
WHAT EMILY WAS SAYING, OF THOSE
PRO-LIFE CENTERS THAT WERE
ATTACKED, FIREBOMBED.
THE TIMES, KAYLEIGH, THAT THE
F.A.C.E. ACT HAS BEEN USED, IT'S
BEEN FOR A VERY EGREGIOUS
SITUATIONS LIKE MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS, LIKE DEATH THREATS.
NOT WHENEVER YOU HAVE A
SITUATION APPARENTLY LIKE THIS,
WHEN THE GUY WAS SHOVED TO THE
GROUND BECAUSE HE WAS HARASSING
SOMEONE'S 12-YEAR-OLD SON.
IT JUST LOOKS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, I THINK, SO MUCH MORE
LIKE -- HE GOES TO A FURTHER
NOTION THAT THIS IS A
POLITICIZED ORGANIZATION, THAT
THEY CHERRY PICKS THIS
PARTICULAR INCIDENT BECAUSE IT
WAS A PRO-LIFE INDIVIDUAL.
THAT'S WHO THEY'RE TARGETING.
>> AND AN ORGANIZATION THAT,
WHEN THE NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION SAYS PARENTS ARE
TERRORISTS, WILL PUT OUT A
LETTER A DAY LATER AND SAY THAT
WE ARE GOING TO LOOK INTO
PARENTS AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS.
>> Brian: THAT'S EXACTLY WHERE
MY HEAD WENT WHEN I SAW THIS
STORY.
A TERRIBLE STORY.
ROSARIES AGAINST GUNS DRAWN,
WHAT A TERRIBLE NARRATIVE.
BUT I THOUGHT OF THAT, AND
PEOPLE GOT CONCERNED WHEN
PARENTS WERE LABELED EXTREMISTS
AND TERRORISTS.
REMEMBER, MERRICK GARLAND SAID,
"I CAN'T IMAGINE A SITUATION
WHERE WE WOULD HAVE TO ACT ON
THIS."
AND I YOU WATCH WHAT'S GOING ON,
I CAN IMAGINE ONE.
I SEE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE
ON THE WRONG SIDE OF POLITICAL
ISSUES, AND IT'S UGLY.
>> Kayleigh: MEANWHILE YOU SAY